avant sa chute voici le mur de berlin à
l'est et à l'ouest
d'un côté un rempart de béton gris et de
l'autre un mur devenu l'exutoire coloré
de dizaines d'artistes du monde entier
pour les peintres c'est la plus grande
toile du monde et ils s'en donnent à
coeur joie
côté ouest les messages d'amitié d'amour
finissent par humaniser le rempart de
béton hal est impossible d'imaginer
pareille audace l'accès aux murs
surveillé par les gardes armés était
temps possible ceux qui s'y aventurent
et risquer la prison et même parfois la
mort à l'ouest touché au mur et est
aussi interdit mais déjouer la
surveillance des gardes y était beaucoup
plus simple et les artistes ne sont
privés pas depuis maintenant bientôt
trois ans avec le kerry noir on a eu
l'idée est reprise et cette idée travail
et enfin ce mur est riche de mur de
berlin dans les années 80 les français
crise dope emmanuel bouchet et thierry
noir font partie des premiers artistes à
s'approprier le mur pour en chasser la
grisaille
nous avons fait ça pour rappeler aux
gens que le mur existe comme un
empaquetage parce que les gens passent
tous les jours tous les jours et ils
oublient que ce mur existe un message
politique mais aussi une envie de donner
une âme à ce mur de béton
le peintre français raymond morey qui
espérait alors que tous les allemands
puissent y participer
un vieux rêve c'est pouvoir peindre le
mur de berlin
les peintres des enfants va les
habitants autour de berlin puisse
s'exprimer sur ce mur et dire ce qu'ils
en pensent un rêve qui devient réalité
le 9 novembre 1989
le jour de la chute du mur de berlin en
quelques heures le béton de l'est prend
rapidement des couleurs pour la première
fois ce matin à berlin est des artistes
et autres tigers ont pu avec
l'autorisation de la police décorer le
mur de berlin
de leur côté à eux de nouvelles couleurs
qui redonnait le sourire aux allemands
de l'est après 28 ans de dictature c'est
merveilleux que ce mur ne soit plus gris
qu'il soit vert ou bleu qu'il est toutes
les couleurs aujourd'hui voici la seule
partie conservée du mur de berlin liste
side gallery 1300 mètres de béton
couverts de fresques dessiné par une
centaine d'artistes la plus grande
galerie en plein air du monde
[Musique]